こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんがだーい好きなおかしいこれ知ってますかたけのこの
里きのこの山みんなもちろんこれの存在知ってると思うんですけどもまぁぶっちゃけ
どっち派ですか僕は生まれてこのとかずっと靴はたけどこのさがかかったんですけど
大人になって量を考えたら
これ
機器の子の方が美味しいちょっと思ってそれから何か物はどっちでもいいやみたいな
正直派閥がなくなって
あのー平和軍になりましたまあ正直ながら的なここ美味しいと思うんですよね僕は
クッキー美味しいんですけども僕的なのはなんといってもこれはこのなんかこのわかる
このよくあたねまりの粉パナこんな手にとって食べるとこんな
運動密着朝礼なぁ sony ページ機能子は大洞ちょっともつけがしっかりあるか手
が汚れないんですよねパソコン触ってることが多くなってきなんだよ手が汚れると
ちょっと作業に支障が出るからなんかあきのこの山の方が好きになってきたのかなって
いう気がするんですけど
正直何が言いたいかというとここに出るんじゃねっていう気はしてましてパッケージも
別にてるじゃないですかそこそこのバカだった
とのこれ気付かないですよというわけで今日の曲だけどこんなさあと中身はきのこの山
に変えてもバレないです
またその逆もしっかり道ですパットにもパッケージはほぼ一緒やん全然違うけど違う
けど似てるんじゃね
正直中身が入れ替わってても全然も全然今感がないわけですよ
今の状況など期の頃に山を開けると木スポンサードは出てきてもこれなんか区
どんなに不自然じゃないですよね
たけのこの里を開けて日の本読んでてきて食べても
うーんまぁそんな気付かないよっていう
いや気づくは多分よっ分意識してないと気付かないと思うんですよ方が家にも
ターゲットかにいるんですけどもまぁ
こっそりこっそりもうたけどこのさとパットはたしてありがとう1号ペリって言って
断っちゃって食べて食べたものがたけのこの里の中身の域の子でも
気付かないと思いますはいではやっていきましょー裏から中身だけを出していきますの
で壊すと元も子もねえからな慎重にいかせてもらうぜ
マートでなおすぐ ok でた東京鳩居堂
これ何十しょうもないこと言ってるの方のりでバレないにしっかり固めていきます
これでしばらくくっつけます一見召募ない企画に見えると思うんですけれどもかなり
高度な
脳内戦を繰り広げられる企画になっておりますだけのこの作なになってもう目にして
box て来ないんでわかるじゃないですか
ただ開いた瞬間たけのこの里っていう要素がこの画面がないわけですけど僕して来ない
けどねあ亭がしっかりたけのこつの里っていう意識が残っているだったら答えられるか
もしれないんですけどもう木田俊寛のチョコレートがを稼いだという
認識たけのこの策だという認識がチョコレートとかお菓子の認識に変わった瞬間今から
食べようとしているこれが何なのかっていう保有イメージというものの記録簿埋め
ちゃってお腹制定とますます食べたいという要求になってそのものの小指とか忘れ
ちゃうんで開けた瞬間の情報量の少なさと食べたいという風の食欲によくこんな的な
部分に対してやるべきだけど手袋里かきのこの山って区別
いきなり意識を持てるかどうかが今回のポイントになっております可能性として本人が
と実もないたけのこの里シンジャパキノコのたと信者だったらすぐ違いがわかると思う
んですけどそこまで本当にこだわりがなかったらまずれると思うよだれでも意外と短
いけると思うので2口かけていこうと思います汚れ
[音楽]
マーコ氏がいたよこっちのうんこっち両面コツできるはずと一瞬ティリティ
ダメ子トイレだって
んすごいん
ポッ
ブームでタイプのんそこがそこによっていないずっとブームねー
作業道です
もう全国的に言われてるんだよ
それ姉が分るんご
ねゴックンっ
さーああああ
あれよと微笑むあっと連携
けがに凝ってる今なぜくらい何やるんです
ちゃんとねそれで俺
それがえっよく食べる駅そばたまーに
ん
[音楽]
水属性だと受けます
えっ
にくれるえっ
ねえ
願った
me
car
あっはぁ
いい
よく
何
はぁそこにがあっこれが近くである